they said i should be denounced and i
should never be hired again
so that was pretty tricky so i then
hired a lawyer
straight away and i said you've got to
withdraw that statement and all that
sort of stuff and pay my costs which
they did that was good
but still the thing about these great
attacks that people
launch on you is once they've launched
the attack on you it sticks
as long as they throw enough [ __ ] some
of it will stick so they
you know you sort of walk around but
weirdly when i walk around the
streets people come up to me and go
thank god for you but when i walk around
on twitter people come up to me and go
i hope you and your family die soon yeah
standard game
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
british actor
and activist he's also the founder of
the reclaim party and hopefully
the next mayor of london lawrence fox
welcome to the reuben report
hi dave how you doing i'm doing just
fine sir i am glad to talk to you
across the pond uh for my american
audience that maybe
doesn't know who you are can you give me
the quick
recap of lawrence fox before we talk
about all the reasons
that you got yourself into trouble and
how you got into politics and all that
well i was an actor and um actually some
of your american
friends will know me because i got off
the plane at jfk once and
and a guy was helping me in my bags he
said i love you in the
inspector louis show so um that was
quite sweet i was active for many years
and then yeah like you say
i got into trouble i got cancelled all
right so let's talk
about your cancellation you were on uh
a british show called question time it's
about about a year ago now
and we're going to play a clip in just a
second but can you just sort of set up
what question time is and how you even
got involved in it as an actor
and uh a little bit of the behind the
scenes portion
sure yeah um so question time is a sort
of topical panel show
uh political panel show in the uk it's
been around for donkeys years
and um it's usually quite very
left-leaning you know and sort of very
establishment
but by some accident they invited a
slightly
more centrist panel on and i was
promoting because i'm a musician as well
so i was promoting an album and someone
said to me do you want to go on question
time and i'm like yeah sure you know
because
it's a sort of family tradition in the
uk people just shout at the tv and go
it's rubbish
no you're wrong and i thought i'd get to
do that on
live tv um and then yeah this
uh a woman started asking questions of
of me it's saying asking what my opinion
was about something and i
said what my opinion was she disagreed
and said i wasn't allowed an opinion
because i was white
so i was like oh hang on that's racist
so i said don't be racist
and then uh boom so let's
we're gonna just throw to that one 30
second clip right now
let's be really clear about what this is
let's call it by its name
it's racism they're the most tolerant
lovely country
in europe
what worries me about your comment is
you are a white privileged male
who hasn't always
can i can't help what i am i was born
like this it's an immutable
characteristic so to call me a white
privileged male is to be racist
so boy you claimed
that you're entitled to opinion even
though you're white how radical of you
it's awful isn't it i mean we should
have learned by now that you're not
allowed an opinion
immutable characteristics ahead of
everything else but it was weird i i was
not
i didn't know it was such an enormous
landmine in the uk so it was
it was crazy the next day i got a bit of
support and then it just went mad
left uh twitter went went for me yeah so
can you talk about that experience
because you know obviously
we're in the midst of this just insane
cancel culture thing and on any given
day we're taking out pepe le pew or mr
potato head or aunt jemima
or so or sometimes real people too um
but can you just talk about what it
feels like
to be the target of that because that's
when you came on my radar suddenly i was
you know it was basically like oh here's
a guy telling the truth
and then just to watch the mob
send on you it was it was
i was okay until the actors union the
equity the actors union you know you
know how um non-left-wing
show business oh yes yes yeah they're
very fair
they went they asked they asked they
said i should be denounced
and i should never be hired again so
that was pretty tricky
so i then hired a lawyer straight away
and i said you've got to withdraw that
statement and all that sort of stuff and
pay my costs which they did that was
good
but still the thing about these great
attacks that people
launch on you is once they've launched
the attack on you it sticks
as long as they throw enough [ __ ] some
of it will stick so they
you know you sort of walk around but
weirdly when i walk around the
streets people come up to me and go
thank god for you but when i walk around
on twitter people come up to me and go
i hope you and your family die soon yeah
standard game right so what would you
say to the people who would say oh but
this is just
some online thing then it's just the
twitter mob and you should get over just
people being mean on twitter you don't
have to be on twitter
well it twitter is pointless and a sewer
of humanity which is fine but um
it's but also it does affect people in
real life like the mayor of london the
sitting mayor of london at the moment
sadiq khan he's like
he takes sort of virtue signing our
identitarianism to a whole new level
of division he called me in the
newspaper when they were asked for a
comment about me he called me a far
right extreme far right guy and i'm like
okay that's pretty uncool because i've
got two kids
i can walk to around the shop if someone
who's only ever read that little bit of
newspaper which is the
capital city newspaper and someone
decides they want to put a brick or a
knife into me
then this whole sort of freedom of
speech thing because i'd actually defend
his right to call me an extreme far
right whatever he wants to call me
he's a bit of a wanker to be fair i
don't care but um we'll get to him in
just a moment
you know when they say that they go
freedom of speech and then freedom of
consequences of the freedom of speech
i'm like if my kids get attacked or if i
get attacked who's the consequences on
are they on you and also can you say one
simple thing that i've ever said which
is even vaguely by the way
right so okay so basically the usual
story unfolds you say a very moderate
thing in line with british values
defending free speech which is really
what you were doing on the
on the panel the whole time uh next
thing you know the mayor is calling you
far right there's a gajillion hit pieces
you've got the union going after you the
twitter mob like
all of that stuff and then you
sort of i think once you got over it you
kind of embraced it because your life in
the last year i mean you started a
political party you're running for mayor
you you kind of ran right into the fire
you can't do anything else there's no
there's no option
there's no i'm i'm good friends with
winston marshall as well and you know
i've been watching from mumfords and
watching while he's trying to put out
there he's trying to bow to the woke mob
and you know and he's
he's actually trying to do the right
thing really but i'm just sat there
going
don't do it buddy yeah don't do it to be
clear he's the
he's the guitarist guitarist right for
mumford inside
player banjo player from bumper designs
he's the one who dared
to recommend andy knows scary book about
antifa i mates with both of them
and i'm on the phone to both of them and
andy's andy's in the uk at the moment
because i want andy's come and work for
for me for the party i really would like
that so um i'm mates with both them it's
hilarious
and they love each other and then
there's this sort of public
crap storm going on around well you know
different approaches to deal with a woke
mob who you can never say sorry to
yeah they love it has he heard any of
your feelings about this like
that you just can't apologize that this
is gonna get you nowhere i mean he's not
even in the band anymore right at least
temporarily
i was speaking we were laughing about it
on on the phone you know it's really
difficult it's like how do you if you're
a
he's a truly compassionate gentle guy he
doesn't want
major conflicts in life i know i don't
mind being punched in the face
for stuff i believe in but i think he's
just trying to do the right thing
and actually i you know i think you can
people that do give in they need more
love because
you know it's it's just people hanging
around the guillotine right going
more more beheadings you know that's
what they're like it's
it's gives me the shivers i like
standing up to them
they need it well and they they do need
it so all right so
assuming that you're not far right i'm
willing to
go on this adventure with you okay
because
in your twitter bio you describe
yourself as a fierce
liberal what does liberal
mean to you at this point because i know
there's a slightly different
british version you know my feelings on
classical liberalism
do you think the word liberal can be
saved does it even make sense
in in the sort of modern context anymore
i think yeah you do have a site uh
difficulty with it in america don't you
because i've got some
american friend bought me a mug saying
liberal tea is still warm but so
but that's leftists to us here right um
i am my liberalism is would now
probably with the overton window where
it is in
society would probably be seen as quite
right-wing you know i want people to get
on with their own lives make their own
decisions about what they do
and keep as much of their money as
possible then not pay it to an enormous
state so
you know it's just about being free to
make your own decisions in life that's
where my liberalism comes from
um and yeah i think we can save it
because ultimately it's going to be
weirdly it's going to be the left of
center liberals that
that save the situation because until
they start standing up
there's no point in people like me going
guys there's a big problem here with
freedom of speech we're going to have a
big fight if we're not careful
we need people from the left to come in
and go this isn't cool
and it's starting to happen they're
eating their own if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about
international issues instead of non-stop
yelling check out our international
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews
on a variety of topics check out our
full episode playlist they're all right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell